look at this famous deleted scene in
terminator 2 judgement day we're looking
directly at arnold schwarzenegger and
linda hamilton's reflections but we
can't see the camera capturing it all
that's because that's not really a
mirror and this reflection of hamilton
isn't actually her filmmakers have
mastered the art of hiding their cameras
from a mirror using visual trickery and
precise cameras and choreography
today they can shoot mirrors in ways
that once seemed impossible
[Music]
innovative mirror shots stretch back to
the beginning of film like when orson
welles captured the now iconic funhouse
mirror sequence in 1947's the lady from
shanghai of the 80 mirrors in the
sequence some were actually two-way
mirrors
while wells and rita hayworth acted on
the reflective side of the glass the
camera could shoot everything from the
non-reflective side without being
detected
two-way mirrors are still useful today
it chapter 2 used them for its
terrifying funhouse sequence to switch
between the reflections of this kid and
pennywise but a convincing mirror shot
doesn't necessarily need to use a real
mirror
like that scene from terminator 2 where
sarah connor removes the chip from the
t-800s head
the camera was directly behind the
characters but it's nowhere to be seen
in the reflection that's because for
this trick the mirror is actually a
window looking into a duplicate version
of the set performers stand on either
side of the reflection mimicking each
other's movements
so hamilton can be seen here but her
reflection is actually the actress's
twin sister next to schwarzenegger and
schwarzenegger's silhouette in the
foreground well that's a very lifelike
dummy the body double trick works best
with twin actors otherwise filmmakers
have to make sure to avoid the devil's
face as seen in this mirror shot from
1995's lahain and this technique is also
prone to human error take this shot from
2011 sucker punch if you look closely
you'll notice the timing of the
actresses and their doubles is slightly
off to avoid this issue and let actors
focus on acting instead of imitating a
body double filmmakers turn to cgi
first the crew will shoot the actor in
front of a mirror then they will film
just the background behind the actor vfx
artists then wipe away the camera by
swapping in pieces of the clean plate of
the reflected background this allows for
the kinds of shots once thought to be
impossible however the process isn't as
easy as it sounds take these mirror
shots from 2014's birdman to perfectly
match the background shots they had to
make sure the lighting was identical in
each pass and the artists had to be
careful where they cut for this one
close up you'll see green tape on the
camera this helped the vfx artist avoid
cutting out any of michael keaton's hair
the process gets even trickier if the
camera is moving
take this legendary shot from 1997's
contact where one shot seemingly turns
into the reflection on a medicine
cabinet mirror to make this work
director robert zemeckis broke it up
into multiple shots and replaced the
entire mirror with cg first as a mecha
set actress jenna malone run towards the
camera instead of filming her from
behind the camera was placed on a
steadicam allowing for smooth shots and
repeated takes after running down the
hall malone reached for the knob of the
medicine cabinet but instead of a mirror
there was a blue screen then the crew
shot the bathroom background on its own
and placed it as well as the texture of
a mirror on top of the blue screen
this one shot was so influential you
still see similar styles decades later
like in this episode of hbo's euphoria
all these tricks and more were used in
2021's last night in soho production
designer marcus roland and vfx
supervisor tom proctor of dneg had to
build a world of mirrors while avoiding
cameras in the final shot the cafe de
perry set alone was lined with an
estimated 178 mirrors which all needed
accurate reflections but they had to do
much more than remove the camera since
eloise played by thomason mackenzie
frequently looks in the mirror and sees
sandy played by anya taylor joy and vice
versa and many of the mirror shots were
incredibly active
so like contact before it they used
steadicams relying on the consistent
movements from chris bain to get shots
like this
and this over and over for key scenes
with multiple multifaceted mirrors and
large camera moves the team relied on
motion control cameras since their moves
are programmed in advance it made it
easier to do separate takes of both
actresses walking down the stairs and to
make sure the leads match their
movements precisely soho brought in a
movement coach for weeks of preparation
to allow the stars to interact more
directly the soho team had to build
several double sets this shot here where
eloise first walks into the cafe de
perry and sees sandy in the mirror the
two actresses were actually facing each
other on set roland built a double lobby
allowing for direct interaction between
the actresses and just like in
terminator 2 they used a real set of
twins to tie the illusion together but
the shot could go from just eloise's
reflection to sandy's with no visible
cuts thanks to adjustable mirrors when
the attendant takes off eloise's jacket
they're standing in front of a real
mirror then one of the twins walks in
front of the camera this gave the crew
just enough time to push the mirror away
allowing sandy to step in
and as a viewer you'd never know there
wasn't a mirror there thanks to this
very subtle bevel added to the edge of
the mirror with cgi
every mirror scene presented its own
challenges so in some cases the team had
to rely on two tricks at once like here
where taylor joyce stands in front of a
mirror with matt smith whose real
reflection is caught in the mirror smith
is in front of a real mirror but the
rest of the glass is cgi
for the final touches soho utilized the
most subtle vfx improvements to avoid
any continuity errors for example
procter and his team inserted green
screen shots of extras into many final
shots to cover up the rough edges of
where a camera was cut out and for any
mismatched mirror movements visual
effects artists use digital re-timing
tools they could get into shots frame by
frame and individually speed up or slow
down individual characters bringing them
into perfect alignment
[Music]
you